wo ist mein handy wo ist mein handy
entschuldigung ich habe dich nicht
verstanden
ich habe dich gefragt wo mein handy ist
das weiß ich nicht keine ahnung
es liegt
dem fernseher
es liegt neben dem fernseher
[Musik]
es liegt auf dem tisch
auf dem tisch
ist es in deiner jackentasche ist es in
deiner jackentasche nein es ist nicht in
meiner jackentasche
nein es ist nicht in meiner jackentasche
wo bist du so bist du was
sag mir wo du bist
ich bin in der
schule ich bin in der schule
ich bin im einkaufszentrum
ich bin in einem restaurant
ich bin in der bank ich bin in der bank
ich bin im bus
ich bin im bus ich bin bei der frisörin
ich bin bei der frisörin ich bin beim
arzt
ich bin beim arzt
ich bin bei tom
ich bin bei tom ich bin zu hause
ich bin zu hause
ich bin in berlin
wohin gehst du wohin gehst du
ich gehe
die schule ich gehe in die schule
einkaufszentrum
ich gehe ins einkaufszentrum
ich gehe in
restaurant ich gehe ins restaurant
ich gehe in die bank
ich gehe an die bushaltestelle ich gehe
an die bushaltestelle
ich gehe zur friseurin
ich gehe zur frisörin ich gehe zum arzt
ich gehe zum arzt
ich gehe zu tim ich gehe zu tun
ich gehe nach hause
[Musik]
ich gehe nach
ich gehe nach berlin
was wirst du am wochenende machen
was wirst du am wochenende machen was
hast du mich gefragt was
hast du mich gefragt ich habe sich
gefragt was du am wochenende machen
wirst
ich habe
sagt was du am wochenende machen wirst
ich weiß es noch nicht
ich habe
keine pläne ich habe keine
pläne ich fahre mit meiner familie in
die berge
ich fahre mit meiner familie in die
berge dort
wir wandern dort
wir wandern ich werde
skifahren ich werde
skifahren
ich werde ausschlafen
warum bist du nach deutschland gekommen
ich bin nach deutschland
gekommen weil ich hier eine arbeit
gefunden habe
ich bin nach deutschland gekommen weil
ich hier eine arbeit gefunden habe
ich von meiner heimat flüchten musste
ich bin nach deutschland gekommen weil
meine frau deutsche ist
bist du glücklich warum bist du
glücklich
sorry ich habe nicht richtig zugehört
was hast du mich gefragt
ich wollte wissen warum du glücklich
bist ich wollte wissen warum du
glücklich bist ich bin glücklich weil
die sonne scheint
ich bin glücklich weil die sonne scheint
ich bin glücklich weil ich die deutsch
prüfung bestanden habe
prüfung bestanden habe ich bin glücklich
weil meine fußball mannschaft gewonnen
hat
ich bin glücklich weil meine fußball
mannschaft gewonnen hat
ich bin glücklich weil ich einen neuen
job gefunden habe
ich bin glücklich weil ich mich verliebt
habe
bist du traurig warum bist du traurig
das möchte ich dir nicht erzählen
com
mehr kannst du schon erzählen warum du
traurig bist
hier kannst du schon erzählen warum du
ich bin traurig weil es seit tagen
regnet
ich bin traurig weil meine katze
gestorben ist
ich bin traurig weil meine freundin mich
verlassen hat ich bin traurig weil meine
freundin mich verlassen hat
ich bin traurig weil mir gekündigt
worden ist
bist du nervös wann bist du nervös
ich bin nervös wenn ich eine prüfung
habe
ich bin
wenn ich eine prüfung habe
ich bin nervös wenn ich nicht gut
geschlafen habe
ich bin
wenn ich nicht gut geschlafen habe
ich bin nervös wenn ich viel arbeit habe
ich bin nervös wenn ich viel kaffee
getrunken habe
ich bin nervös bin ich auto fahre ich
bin nervös wenn ich auto fahre
wirst du wütend wann wirst du wütend
ich werde wütend wenn ich im stau stehe
ich werde wütend wenn ich früh aufstehen
muss
ich werde wütend wenn jemand zu spät
kommt
kommt ich werde wütend wenn meine kinder
ihr zimmer nicht aufräumen
ich werde
wütend wenn meine kinder ihr zimmer
nicht aufräumen
ich werde wütend wenn die nachbarn lärm
machen
[Musik]
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal reden
sonntag ein neues video